all right so I'm as opposed aid and I do
work at the intersection of data
management and HCI I want to give you a
brief intro about myself
so like Michael said I started out as a
database researcher in fact my first few
projects were all pretty much back-end
databases how can we make it one faster
how can I help the yahoos in the googles
with their large data you know how can I
run a query in a sub-millisecond time
instead of you know 10 milliseconds and
then something happened right I got
tired of sort of helping the googles and
the Yahoo's and I wanted to help normal
folk with their data and so I flew all
the way from the east coast to the west
coast it was that transformative in
terms of what I needed to do and started
working with Joe Hellerstein at UC
Berkeley and in fact when I joined it
was a semester we would look at a few
problems think about what we want to do
to help users with their data Joe
suggested that I come attend the data
visualization course here in Stanford
taught by Jeff here so I spent a
semester I wasn't even formally auditing
I would just crash his course and it
really helped sort of formulate my ideas
about what it means when people look at
data how do they see and understand data
and that sort of guided a lot of my
research so since then I joined the
faculty at NYU Abu Dhabi we actually are
located in a place called Satya which is
better
okay so Satya literally means happy
island so we've been happy since and
I've been working mostly on what I'd
like to call example driven interfaces
and I'll define that a little bit later
in my talk there has there been some
back-end database research that I've
been doing and I'd like to sort of keep
my my foot in boat places
and there's a whole slew of projects
that I've built that are sort of that
fall under this umbrella team of example
driven interfaces so that's it about me
in terms of you know my professional
research life and my personal life I
just had a baby who's nine months old
and he's been tagging along with me if
you see a screaming crying baby and a
loss dad that could be my husband and
son roaming around and Stanford alright
so I guess that's it for an intro I'd
like to start the talk by sort of
engaging in this thought experiment with
you I want you to sort of think for a
few seconds about how you would describe
what furniture is perhaps to somebody
next to you perhaps to an alien what is
furniture does anybody want to volunteer
a definition or just an explanation of
what furniture is sure very well an
abstract expression definition of what
furniture is if you thought of a couch
or a chair maybe you even thought about
a table then perhaps you're a database
person but that's normally what people
would do is sort of think about a
concrete object right and when you
talked about objects around in your home
you were sort of reflecting on things
that define what furniture is but you
referred or you thought about or your
reflected on an example right so if you
get that then this is what cognitive
scientists would basically call exempt
larvae strees inning prototyping you
sort of fell back on a prototype and
that could be a chair a couch it could
differ from person to person but the
idea is that you went back to an example
and this sort of mode of thinking is
very pervasive people have studied
firefighters and how they sort of deal
with situations when they look at a fire
they don't necessarily reflect back on
the manual they reflect back on a
similar fire that they've seen and then
decide what their next action is when
when they've studied radiologists
looking at x-rays of tumors again they
don't necessarily think about you know
what are the X many characteristics of
what a tumor is they sort of reflect
back on similar tumors that they've seen
and how close the current x-ray is to
those passive examples now many other
fields have latched on this idea that we
think with examples or we communicate
with examples advertisers or marketers
for example will sell you examples of
how an object is used when trying to
promote it right if you looked at the
Fitbit website you've got all these you
know fit people sort of promoting the
Fitbit right and it's so pervasive I
went ahead and bought a Fitbit thinking
I'd look like those people and that
never happened and I don't really use
the Fitbit that much but I do own it
right you know people use that one
seeking advice right people go by
Trump's you know how do you be how do
you negotiate the art of the deal right
or in this case they buy you know Tom
Brady's book to sort of figure out what
they want to do to sort of get into a
stronger fitter shape yeah there was a
phase in my life where I was like I need
to get back in shape and so lots of lots
of money spent not much in terms of like
what happened all right
so I want to use this idea of examples
to help people communicate with their
data tools and get the most out of it
and so from that this whole idea of an
example driven interface came to mind
now would it be a bit more specific
about a bit more concrete to use an
example of what I mean right so suppose
I want to buy a box of chocolates right
in the normal form we'd go to a store
we'd meet a chocolatier and we'd say
well you know I want to buy a box of
chocolates I want it to have some white
chocolates and dark chocolates and then
we'd work together in a series of
conversations right or questions he'd
say well do you want it like this
and I'll be like no maybe I want more
dark or maybe I want less nuts right and
then he asked me for a few more options
right but the thing is we'd work
together through a series of questions
and answers where we're mostly sort of
asking does this example fit your needs
or not right and finally we'd end up
with the perfect chocolate box
now how you interact with a database is
completely different
suppose I replace this chocolatier with
a database then my mode of interaction
would basically be issue this horrendous
sequel query which Mayer name may not be
correct right and I'd have to think
about it right at the get-go I have to
formulate a very precise idea of what I
want because the language is very
precise and so I'm possibly gonna get
that first formulation incorrect and it
doesn't matter that you know it's not
exactly what I have to what I want Oh
issue it anyway against the database
potentially wait a long time depending
on how difficult the query is or how
many chocolates exist in that database
and then I end up with lots and lots of
boxes that define or that sort of are
correct answers for the query but they
may not be correct answers for what I
intended and I'd have to like sift
through them to pick one or go back and
reformulate my query so the the two
forms of interaction are very different
and clearly we want something more
humane right and so what I mean by an
example driven interface is something
that sort of mimics that chocolates here
in that it allows us to specify what we
want perhaps ambiguously perhaps vaguely
and then work with us in a series of
interactions towards a more precise
definition of what we want right you
could use these edie eyes for a variety
of tasks and that's what I what we did
in our research to sort of use these
EDIS for data extraction
for debugging data pipelines for sequel
queries that was my very first project
even for data generation I show an
example for time series querying later
as well so the rest of the talk is
basically outlined like this we've
already sort of given an idea of what
these example driven interfaces are I'll
be talking about why now is the right
time to look at these how to build them
sort of a quick recipe for how you could
put together an EDI and then sort of
discuss when things work and when they
don't right so I wish I could say every
time you design an EDI it's gonna work
we've seen more failures than successes
and I'm gonna go through an example of
that and then where do we go from here
what's next you know if you want to do
this kind of research what should you do
or what I think are interesting venues
to look into okay so why now is the
right time and it's a fair question
because this idea of doing things by
example existed for a while right this
is a very early paper in my community in
the database community on query by
example from the 1970s and it never took
off right it's it's a very well sighted
paper but there hasn't been any sort of
known or widely used example driven or
at least the way sleuth intended it
interfaces for databases well the reason
I think now is the right time is because
since then there are a variety of fields
that have matured in computer science
and if we look at the confluence of them
we have so much power now that we could
make them work we could make these
interfaces do things that we couldn't
have made them do previously and the
very first research area that mature
does this program synthesis area so it
started out very early by Church where
he looked at sort of simple circuit
synthesis right it was like that's kind
of boring that's not what
you want to do with your data right now
but since then there has been lots of
work in terms of well how can you use
more than just examples suppose I give
you examples of what the input and the
output should be but I also give you a
simple program sketch and so then the
work of Solara Lezama came in and it
sort of looked at ways to make this
efficient right there's a huge space of
what programs are correct given a few
input output examples searching that
space needs to be efficient if you want
this to sort of occur at the at the
within an interaction time right you do
not expect you know your chocolatier you
give them an example of what you want
you say well in a box up with some white
chocolates and then this appear for ten
minutes and come back and be like is
this close to what you want or that you
want sort of quick interaction times
right so efficiency is key when you're
trying to synthesize these programs
these queries these data extraction
scripts and so on
and since then you know PBE or
programming by example has become
mainstream do any of you use Excel
everybody does right has anybody tried
out the flash fill feature to the
researchers room whenever you used it
for actual tasks okay cool we've got one
person or that it's pretty cool try it
out you basically give a few examples of
what you want let's say you know
differently formatted telephone numbers
and then you know how you want me at the
telephone numbers to be formatted and
then you say flash fill and it will
automatically transform all your
telephone numbers so you can do that
with with any kind of data you know
formatting first names last names what
you want addresses so it's pretty cool
and now it's mainstream the second area
that has sort of evolved and this comes
from HCI
is this idea of mixed initiative user
interfaces how many of you know who
clicky is right is the most annoying
right or not there's a huge debate now
but for people who use the Clippy which
I remember was during my high school
years or something I found it really
annoying
I found that Clippy interferes way too
much gives the wrong advice all the time
the idea was pretty cool but you know it
was automation done in an invasive form
and if you think about these easy eyes
they're in a way trying to automate the
construction of a query the construction
of a data extraction strip script from a
few example so there's automation
involved from a few human interactions
and and so you have to be careful about
how you design it and Clippy I would say
was a great idea done wrong right so
since then eric Horvitz work came out
which sort of outlined principles of how
you should design these mixed initiative
user interfaces where the user does a
little bit and then the system sort of
tries and automates from there now since
then Clippy died which was good news for
all I think bye-bye cliff Pete don't you
know going to his grave
it's sort of a loud room for all these
interfaces or for the idea of automation
to come back again
in the correct way and so we have tools
right now for example for data wrangling
or data cleaning like trifecta where it
would suggest at every interaction you
click a column it will suggest you know
ideas for how you want to transform that
column you highlight something it will
suggest scripts for what you want to
extract based on what you highlighted
and it's sort of this predictive
interaction at every step that the user
takes so I think that those ideas are
sort of really helpful when it comes to
designing these example driven
interfaces the third area and there are
five so we're getting there
is learning theory or active learning
and the reason why this is important to
us is active learning helps us sort of
expand the examples that we have
to learn the correct behavior from right
if you provide only a few examples and
you try to infer what the program is you
could be very much under specified and
what active learning allows us to do is
not only ask the right questions to sort
of get you know more informative
examples from the users but it also
allows us to sort of learn scripts to
learn what the user thinks is a correct
or an incorrect example to then feed
into the program inference stage so
active learning can really expand the
examples that we have allowing us to
generate more correct programs or
scripts of what the user wants and
there's really interesting work by Chris
Rea who's at Stanford and those data
management research and sort of acts of
learning through this tool that he built
that's called snorkel so if you're
interested I'd you know please go and
check it out the other thing that's
important is this research and causality
and explanations and really it started
as a field and philosophy right and and
then moved on into AI and now it's
becoming even more important in in the
database area because if you get a
certain output from a data
transformation or a data exploration
script you want to know why it came
about and so causality and explanation
sort of explained sort of work backwards
through the provenance through the
lineage of the data to explain why
something is an answer right and there's
been a lot of research in this area and
I think it's really important for EDIS
because you have that aspect of
automation you might want to know why a
certain script was chosen by your EDI as
the correct script or why certain query
was picked by it especially if it didn't
meet your needs and finally the last
area of improvement that occurred in the
spam from the 70s up till now is
visualization and automated
visualization Indic
we're ative languages for visualization
and the more visualization research
improves the better it is for data
research in general and data interfaces
because we like to think of her data
visually right it is impossible to think
of a million tuples if we're given a
table right but it is much easier to
make sense of it if we have the correct
visualization in place with that in mind
if I have a beautiful visualization of
my data interacting with it is the next
important step right and so interactive
visualizations which are going to become
easier if you have clean languages for
visualizations help us sort of extract
examples from the users of what they
want which in turn helps us to
appropriately query analyze the data and
so on all right so now that these areas
have sort of given us what we need to
sort of build these et eyes how can we
actually go about and build them right
and this is sort of a very quick and
dirty recipe that you could get from
reading submit kiwannis book on
programmed synthesis and he sort of
defines a few dimensions really he says
three dimensions in ten specification
search space and search techniques and I
add an ambiguity resolution as a fourth
important dimension there so what does
that mean well then the first thing is
you want to figure out what's the most
natural way to get what the user intends
to do with their data now in some cases
it could be here's my data here's what I
want the output to look like in some
cases that's very difficult to get from
the user or it's very unnatural to ask
the user to do that right or it might
just be to under specified at that case
and you need a little bit more perhaps
you need hints of what the query should
look like or you need hints of what the
analysis should include sometimes you
just need to provide binary you know
answer not answer
these are what we call positive or
negative examples and in in some cases
like I'm gonna show later perhaps a
sketch a drawing of what they want right
the search space is the next very
important task and remember that when
you have when you're thinking about data
analysis scripts the space is enormous
even simple queries even simple boolean
queries sort of queries that return
answers or non answers as their result
that space space is massive right it's
astronomer call searching it given one
or two examples is a problem so what you
end up have to doing and really this is
where a lot of the art in building these
easy eyes comes in it's sort of trying
to decide how can i scope it out in a
way that makes sense and sometimes that
scoping it out comes from observing your
users seeing what are the most commonly
you know what are the most common tasks
that they do and perhaps that defines
your search space right perhaps it comes
down to defining a language that's
simpler than what you can do with your
data but sort of expressive enough and
powerful enough that the users like it
even though it's a simplified version
but it gives you the added benefit that
the space of programs you could
construct with that language is small
enough that these things become
tractable and so you know that this this
art is is also known as sort of Cree Act
creating a syntactic bias right you're
creating a language with a certain
syntax that biases the programs that you
could generate to a certain in a certain
way there's a lot of research in terms
of how you get program synthesis right
how do you define or scope out your
search space you know some people will
say it's it's it's advantages it's
advantageous to create operators in your
data transformation or analysis scripts
that are invertible right
you give it an input it gives you an
output you pass back the output you get
back the input and this is also very
important if you're doing sort of step
by step synthesis where you're sort of
suggesting an operator at a time rather
than a whole program or query or script
at a time then the search technique sort
of though that's the third dimension you
need to think about is how do you sort
of figure out what the most appropriate
programmer script is given the language
given the scope that you've defined
again there are plenty of techniques by
looking at sort of the latest and
greatest in program synthesis you could
sort of pick and choose what you want to
use you could use an SMT solver to help
you or you could use brute force search
right or you could even sort of create
these nice version space algebras which
basically say I'm gonna store the
minimum and the maximum off the programs
that you have rather than everything
that's possible given your your examples
and then ambiguity resolution is the
fort dimension because you need to come
back to the user right you need to come
back and say I don't have enough data I
don't have enough examples give me more
or I think it could be one of these many
programs which one is it and how you do
ambiguity resolution is again part of
the HCI fun that gets into this domain
okay so any questions so far
wicked all right so when do these work
and we could take a very narrow
definition here of working right for me
these easy eyes work if you could
complete a data task in much shorter
time more accurately than the sort of
run-of-the-mill tools that you have that
require you to specify things in a
language or a script or a query language
like sequel so that's that may not be
the best definition of success but it's
something that we could measure measure
and evaluate all right so the first tool
that I built is data play the idea there
is that you have these queries that you
are basically boolean queries so they
either give you answers and/or they
split your entire data set into answers
or non answers so the example here is
something like oh I want to find out all
students who are straight-a students for
example and so I could sort of either
you know and the way this starts is I
need to give a few hints of what my
query ought to be so the hint here is
something like grade equals a so you
could give these small predicates you
don't give the full query but you're
giving small predicates that then the
system sort of assembles and a complete
query for you after you go in here and
you say things like I want to keep the
student in because they're a straight-a
but I want to keep the student out
because you know maybe they're not
straight-a students right but basically
sort of just interacting but the ones
out keep in wanting to keep out you
could sort of structure the query
correctly to meet your needs now one of
the things we've learned by building
data plays that you know examples alone
generally are not enough you need a
little bit of hinting from the users and
in our case and you want to keep the
hints simple so we said well any user
can write simple predicate so you could
write things like they should be in the
cs50 7 course right but it's much
difficult to say something like they
should be taking all courses that are
offered by the HCI school example right
so simple predicates are easy but once
you sort of quantify them it gets more
and more complicated so maybe that's
where you need these examples to help
you sort of structure the full query
right or you could think about your
predicates easily but putting them in a
conjunctive form or the Strunk to form
that might be tricky
so perhaps we could help you with that
the second sort of tool that we built
was around example driven data
extraction so the idea here is you have
this journalist looking at FBI later
really press releases and they're trying
to figure out his crime increased or
decreased over the past few decades
there's
right this is a different one but yeah
that was one of the tasks we did here
it's a simpler example were just
extracting dates from from the data set
and so I could highlight what I want and
then it would suggest sort of different
extraction rules and I could sort of go
in and say you know I could highlight
something and say it's not an example of
what I want and then you know from the
rules I could look at them but also what
the system does for us is something
smart where it sort of looks at what can
be extracted by all the possible rules
that are currently valid and then allows
you to sort of say you know keep in or
not write perhaps you want full dates
but not May 2011 so you could go and
sort of say yes no depending on what is
the what is currently the valid space of
rules given what you just highlighted
all right so it allows you to sort of it
helps you guide or it helps you sort of
guide the synthesis by asking you sort
of mark these tuples or mark these
extractions that are more important than
other than just going through the
document and adding more extractions to
it okay so again this idea of going back
to the user and asking them to sort of
help you distinguish between what you
want or don't want helps a lot with easy
EDIS catch is another interesting tool
that we built for date for time series
screen so time series are things like
stock prices heart rate anything that
changes over time is a time series and
what we found interesting here is that
the banette the most natural way of
providing an example of your what you
want is just the sketch of the pattern
right it's not this time series infer
and this time series out it's this is
what I'm looking for and it's just a
sketch right and then what was really
cool about us building catch is that
when we built it we sort of you know
went top-down right we looked at what
the interface ought to be and that in
turn
changed how we designed our time series
matching algorithms and we found that
the sort of state of the art that's used
by database systems like dynamic time
warping or even Euclidean distance
matching just weren't good enough for
matching sketches to time series data so
we had to recreate a good matching
algorithm for the task and this is what
I like about sort of doing this
intersection research is that you end up
sort of doing things that impact
multiple fields at a time right and
there were several neat things that we
did with sketch you know this idea if
you have a canvas you draw on it well
what more can you do with the drawing
right so we came up with with sort of a
new sketch based language where we said
well maybe I could do regular
expressions over here can I
mark part of my sketch and I say I want
this part to repeat or I want this but
not you know I draw something and I say
everything but what I just drew for
example so a whole regular expression on
top of sketches and then we also did a
few cool things like you know where I
draw something on the canvas it sort of
helps me decide the order of things that
I wanted to appear in a time series so
sort of relative positioning of your
sketches creates an ordered query for
you sinner is an interesting tool that
we're currently building the idea there
is you generate data that you want by
example so you go in and you fill a few
things and then it figures out from
those examples what the domain of the
data is what relationships exist to that
domain and perhaps suggests those to
sort of introduce into your data it can
figure out things like what the
statistical distribution is from the few
examples that you gave and suggest that
perhaps you want to generate numbers
from a normal will help you then later
go back in and tweak it and then what we
also realize is that when you generate
data from a statistical distribution
people have trouble sometimes
understanding that if you want a normal
curve when you
we generate the data it's not gonna fit
that normal curve exactly so we had to
do some cool visualization tricks to
show them you know that yes you've
specified well normal curve but all of
these sort of little things are possible
you know data sets that we could create
sort of giving them this idea that
there's a bit of uncertainty here when
you generate data statistically so again
what that sort of tells us is when you
build these tools you have to sort of
look at things and say well you know
maybe I need to tweak how I visualize
the data back to them to give them the
sense of what is possible or not
possible from tool all right so I gave
you three successes what about the
failures all going to show you one but
there are more and we could talk about
them later this was a joint project with
IBM where they have these data pipelines
and then the end users look at the
outputs and they could be wrong but they
can't really figure out where in the
pipeline the error was introduced where
the bug was but because they could look
at the outputs and say this is correct
or incorrect these are examples that
perhaps we could use to debug the data
pipeline so we created this system
called white flow and the idea is that
they'd look at these outputs they'd say
what is correct or incorrect and then
we'd sort of back propagate through the
whole pipeline you know where the what
the scre echt versus incorrect flow to
sort of figure out which module could be
the source of the error but in addition
to sort of localizing where the module
is we also wanted to generate an
explanation that says you know we think
the errors at this module and this is
the explanation of what that error could
be now didn't it worked and it didn't
work in a way no way did help the the
sort of the end users localize the error
but they did that much longer than if
they manually went through and sort of
debug good so that's the failure but
they did it more correctly when they
used our tool than when they did it
manual
right so manually they were more
confident of where the error was they
returned back at a much quicker time and
said we think this module is the cause
of the error but they were wrong more
often than with our tool so why did it
not work well we think there are several
reasons for that and one of them is this
yes
slower I could very quickly write a
program that fails but it takes me a
long time to write a program that works
because the whole point was to sort of
allow very quick round-trip times right
we wanted these end-users to sort of
figure out these errors and push them
back to like the correct team and these
data pipeline teams to sort of you know
reduce the round-trip time to an error
and so if I push I mean the idea is that
if I push it to a development team they
have their time to sort of come back and
fix it and if I say if I push back
something that's incorrect they could
still they're gonna spend our time and
they're still going to debug it but then
I did not reduce that that time back so
I think it was a business requirement
that they wanted these end-users to sort
of figure out the error quickly and push
it back to the correct team that said I
think there's also you know there's the
numbers sort of say that but it was more
you know like we were 70% better versus
60% better like yes we were they were
more correct using us but not by enough
of a margin for us to feel happy with
what we produced so that lets I think
one one part of it yeah so I guess not
enough for us to go like all guns
blazing and be like we created the best
debugging tool in the world like we just
felt very lukewarm about her
and part of the reason we think we
didn't do so great was this idea that
you could debug by just a few examples
of what this correct and incorrect
debugging is a super hard problem
right you're not only generating the
space a space of possible problems
you're sort of doing a second-order kind
of thing right all the programs that
ought to be fixes for the current
program that's incorrect and so we did
not get the balance right
we needed something more than just
labeling the other thing was that our
setup was that we only use what we call
why provenance this is sort of a
database like the a where basically
you're only tracking what makes it to
the output right and what we needed was
why not provenance which includes things
that did not make it to the output so it
sort of dropped results missed tuples
and so on and and because we didn't have
that aspect there were many errors that
we couldn't actually capture the other
problem was that our search space there
are explanations that we created were
too simplistic so our idea is that these
end users you know they're more you know
they're more comfortable with sort of
the the problem domain but they're not
as comfortable with the modules and in
fact the modules were black boxes to
them so generating an explanation for
what the error could be at a module we
wanted to keep the language as simple as
possible so those simple predicates
the problem is you simplify the language
too much now you can't actually capture
the error with it right or the the
script that's the explanations that you
generated were kind of loose right they
had low precision all right the other
problem was that we tried to use
probabilistic error model models to sort
of better localize where the faulty
module could be
and then and certified to create that
syntactic bias but the problem is these
models only worked if you kind of knew
how modules could you know what what
were the more likely errors in a module
than another right so for example if I
have a filtering module then you know
common errors that I got my trash hold
wrong or I said you know greater than
when it should have been less than right
and I have a probabilistic model that
describes how likely one error is over
the other now if I do that I could get
better localization of where the fault
can be and perhaps better explanations
that sort of fits how how how
programmers commonly create errors but
then I break this blackbuck assumption
that we were working with and then
ambiguity resolution was the last
problem and this is really the key HCI
problem that we saw there was that we
gave these explanations and we rank them
by measures like precision and recall
and you'd end up getting a lot of
explanations with the same precision and
the same recall so we basically are just
doing a dump of explanations and asking
users to sort of figure out what could
have been the cause of the error and so
this sort of ranking was just not right
it wasn't sufficient we needed something
a bit more powerful but we couldn't
figure out what it is so what did work
was the visualization aspect right
people liked us differentiating correct
and incorrect flows and that's helped
them trace the source of the error
better than any probabilistic sort of
error modeling a scheme that we used so
in a way by just visualizing error flows
they themselves manually could sort of
interact with the tool and figure out
the error better than if that wasn't
available as a feature so in Hyden site
everything looks great right okay so
where do we go from here and these are
my last two slides I think there's a lot
of research that could be done on the HC
eyesight especially around how we
visualize the synthesized artifacts how
do we visualize the space of programs
given a few examples and the idea is
that if I could show you that then you
didn't attend a user and if I show you
that in a sort of in a way that's not
too intimidating right like we still
don't want to like dump at them a whole
bunch of say Python scripts right well I
want to show them a space of possible
programs in a way that they could
interact with that space and say oh I
think it's more this program than that
so how can we do that in a way that it's
intuitive to the users and also do it in
conjunction with the examples that
they've already given us and the data
and its effects on the data right so
this is sort of a co visualization
problem that's very hard and if we could
sort of think about how do we visualize
programs with respect to their effect on
the data that would be very important
and I don't think there's a lot of
research in that space but there are
some things that are coming out and this
is becoming more and more important
because people now are dealing with
machine learning and multiple models
that sort of exist and trying to figure
out what is the best model given their
data and then there's a lot and data
research sort of my home field in the
sense that when you build these
interfaces they sort of really change
how you do querying and how you do you
know I've given this example of catch
and how it changed how we did time
series matching but if you think about
it at a bigger scale the the pace at
which interactions happen when you have
these example driven interfaces is so
fast right you have a series of
incrementally different queries coming
out from the user and you want to be
able to support them at sort of
millisecond speeds so that sort of
changes the dynamic that we have with
the data we're no longer issuing a query
that's the correct clear
waiting for results were issuing a
series of queries potentially and we're
also differentiating between these
queries to sort of figure out a way to
help the user guide us to the right
query so there's a lot of exciting
opportunities in the data itself in in
data research and data management itself
to support these interfaces so that's it
for all and happy to receive your
comments and questions I hope I'm within
the time limit
[Applause]